[Music]
if title 10 was eliminated four million
patients would lose their preventive
health care we're in Austin Indiana with
the big HIV outbreak like I say there's
hope a lot of it question to me is
what's gonna happen to women in rural
America who have very little access to
affordable health care we are pulling up
to a Planned Parenthood in suburban
Indianapolis we're gonna try to interact
with some of the protesters who are
trying to convince women coming in not
to have abortions hey how you guys doing
today
sure okay can you guys tell us why why
you're out here every single day like
what are you trying to get across to
women to give them another choice we've
found that most women regret their
abortion and what do you think about the
current debate right now about defunding
Planned Parenthood well I don't think
they should get our
no even though such a small percentage
of the work they do is actually abortion
I do not believe there what about the
the preventive work that they're doing
in terms of you know birth control and
safe sex that kind of makes it so that
there are none wanted pregnancies well
it's kind of like saying I have a great
dry cleaner and he gets my spots out
really well health but in the back he's
having a dogfight going on back there do
we excuse the killing of over it and
this
say the words Planned Parenthood
anywhere in America and you'll be met
with a tidal wave of opinions the
country's largest provider of
reproductive health services it's been
highly controversial since founded by
birth control activists 100 years ago
bro v Wade the landmark 1973 Supreme
Court ruling largely cemented a woman's
right to get an abortion but it hasn't
stopped the pro-life movement from doing
their best to make it as difficult as
possible make no mistake this is a
repeal and a replace of Obamacare make
no mistake about and now with the Trump
administration's crusade to repeal and
replace Obamacare Planned Parenthood is
back in the crosshairs in conservative
America driving divisions to new
extremes life is winning in America
Indiana were pro-life champion Mike
Pence was governor in 2013 to 2016 could
be considered ground zero and recently
pro-life Republicans led by Vice
President Pence have scored a historic
blow against Planned Parenthood and when
they vote to repeal and replace
Obamacare we will finally defund Planned
Parenthood the new proposed health care
plan would block Planned Parenthood from
receiving Medicaid reimbursements for a
year that's about 30 percent of its
funding if if title 10 was eliminated
four million patients across the country
would lose their of their preventative
health care title 10 is the federal
grant that partially funds Planned
Parenthood and there is no provider
network just to step in and take care of
those patients
it would have horrible consequences
in the midst of this battle it's no
wonder Planned Parenthood is going all
out with its annual fundraising gala in
Indianapolis why do you think it's
especially important to contribute to
Planned Parenthood this year well
governor Pence in now president pan says
is the agenda which is not to take
health care or going away from women and
it's just terrible I'm personally
against abortions the best way to reduce
them is to give family planning people
were talking about what it would be like
[Music]
because I know what America under my
principle
and now the grand goddess of the
nationwide fight for reproductive
justice Cecile Richards for Planned
Parenthood president Cecile Richards
holding the line here in Indiana is
crucial to the organization the
challenge now is really because we have
a Congress and administration and then
some state legislators that are frankly
completely committed to ending access to
health care not only at Planned
Parenthood but more broadly perhaps the
biggest harder for Planned Parenthood is
the intense focus on abortion despite
the fact that abortions only account for
3% of their services and taxpayer money
has never funded them lost under the
roar of this battle is the real story
the countless Americans who have the
most to lose if preventative health care
services are cut this is Austin Indiana
in 2015
Austin made national news in a rural
community of around 4,000 people 130 HIV
cases were diagnosed just a few months
well an outbreak of the HIV virus in
Indiana is spreading so fast a team from
the CDC is now involved and the state's
governor was forced to extend a health
emergency declared last month the
outbreak linked to IV drug use force
then governor pence to send it emergency
treatment services and a needle exchange
program and a total cost of almost sixty
million dollars I'm giving the authority
to local officials today to establish a
focus short-term program on the basis of
a public health emergency 24 year old
Morgan Rielly has lived in Austin all
her life I noticed a lot of my friends
from school start to disappear but it
seems like it happened like like
overnight and I I kind of always like
scared me you know until I found myself
in the middle of it it's like the first
time you do it it's just you're you're
sunk right into it
and what was everyone doing like what
pills Oh Pena's and then they
disappeared and then it was just all
heroin and the only way people would do
it would be to shoot it but most of the
drug use and I assume the HIV outbreak
stuff was concentrated right in this
area
yes that's crazy it was like a couple of
blocks but Austin isn't an isolated case
the opioid epidemic is ravaging towns
across the country particularly in rural
America where local economies are
suffering federal health officials say
220 counties across America are at risk
for a drug-related HIV outbreak and many
of these communities are where Planned
Parenthood is a frontline health care
provider
were there any resources in town to like
help you get out of this or help anyone
else get out of this when they were at
when they were going through it didn't
come until after the HIV epidemic that's
when I were you know most of it started
happening to help people in 2011
governor mitch Daniels pence his
predecessor cut off funding to Planned
Parenthood leading to multiple clinic
closures governor mitch Daniels has
promised to sign a bill next week which
will strip Planned Parenthood of federal
funding the last Planned Parenthood in
Scott County closed in 2013 a couple of
years before the HIV cases spiked there
was a Planned Parenthood in a in
Scottsburg that closed out in 2013
do you think that if that was still open
that addicts would have would have gone
to it or would have used it you could
have made a difference um it could've
most definitely yeah I know I use it
whenever I was in high school and then
it closed and then it was just kind of
like okay well guess I'll just do it
this way now you know every year plan
powers of clinics perform more than
650,000 HIV tests these are free for
patients on Medicaid half of our health
centers and we have almost 650 health
centers in the u.s. half of them are in
medically underserved communities and
for so many these women
here in Indiana and Kentucky this may be
the only doctor visit they get all year
and so not only does the planned parent
provide family planning but we provide
your cancer screenings they're relevant
visits again whatever their annual
physical is and these women are
desperately concerned about how they're
going to get access to affordable health
care this map of existing clinics shows
a lot of empty space in the middle of
the country where conservative beliefs
often dictate halls it's not quite as
dire in Indiana but that may change soon
this part of the country has already
been hit with a lot high unemployment
addiction and the health issues that go
along with that
and if the new health care plan leads to
more clinic shutdowns it's about to take
another hit I mean do you remember when
you first heard that you had that you
were HIV positive I don't even remember
it this is how men stuff I was know when
I heard all the rest of my friends you
know saying hey I've got inst and I even
thought well I want to have it if
they've got it that's the way I started
justifying it you could live with it
yeah yeah and then you knew you had it
was it like you in denial or did you
just not care that I don't believe I
even cared yeah you know I just I can't
I guess I can't say I didn't care but
Dora also echoes a point I've heard some
Republicans say that Planned Parenthood
isn't enough for people most at risk for
HIV and that funds could be better spent
on treatment and counseling centers so
if you're dealing with people that's in
deep addiction from my life what I saw
you know I practically would had to have
somebody come to me and they took my
grandchildren I went to rehab so that
gave them more hope you know so they've
got hope now because they see hope in me
I'm hungry cuz won't have to live
through this okay say either's hope a
lot of it I've got a long way to go but
yes it's a really life worth living
if passed the new healthcare plan would
direct federal family planning funds to
community health centers these health
centers don't offer abortions and for
politicians and voters in this part of
the country that's still what matters
most hey senator thank you so much for
taking the time to do this with us I
really appreciate it
Kentucky state senator max wise authored
a bill to divert state funds from
Planned Parenthood in Kentucky we you
know we have over 538 community health
department in clinics that are available
for women to go to you know
Planned Parenthood does not do what we
call true family planning when we looked
at you know 2014-15 you know Planned
Parenthood nationwide perform 323,000
some abortions and so you know Kentucky
you want to take a stance and I think
other states are gonna follow suit for
religious conservatives like Kentucky
governor Matt Bevin as long as Planned
Parenthood is an abortion provider
nothing else they do matters in 2016
governor Bevin sent a cease and desist
letter to this brand-new Louisville
Planned Parenthood clinic how long was
your facility open for a day a single
day a day our abortion services side our
Family Planning side has remained open
the basis of Bevins suit was a small
code violation some missing paperwork
with an ambulance company so you have
this like brand-new super updated
facility and you guys just can't use it
no no it's a facility that is
encompassing of a recovery room surgical
rooms the fact that it's remained empty
now for the last year and a half has
been really heartbreaking to a lot of us
because we know the barriers for so many
are insurmountable in this area now
governor Bevin has turned his attention
to the last place to get illegal
abortion in Kentucky the private EMW
clinic in Louisville
let us pray that uh pro-lifers has
spread this victory to every segment of
our society earlier this year
governor Bevin ordered this clinic to
shut down citing a similar code
violation we had three abortion clinics
with are now down to one there's only
one left in the Commonwealth of Kentucky
we are a pro-life state the ACLU
intervened to keep EMW open and a trial
to determine the clinic's fee is set for
September of 2017
the abortion clinic is still operating
but women coming here face protesters
every single day
[Music]
what motivates you to come come down
here and protest outside this clinic our
hope is really to help these women turn
away from abortion we want to turn these
women call them away from abortion call
them to hope but the Bible says about
life and womb in Psalm 139 it said you
know it uses just graphic just depictive
language about God meeting a child
together in the womb so I really want to
plead with a woman because what we're
talking about is life adding red tape
are passing parental consent laws are
some of the ways pro-life politicians
are making abortions much harder to get
this has already been going on for years
in many conservative states I long to
see the day the Roe versus Wade is
consigned to the ash heap of history
where it belongs the way this plays out
is that officials are able to restrict
abortion to the state level without
needing to take on roe v wade in the
Supreme Court
[Music]
the Trump administration says they might
allow federal funding for Planned
Parenthood in the future if they stop
performing abortions but the
organization is clear they won't abandon
a service that consider central to their
mission women have always figured out
how to end their pregnancies that's gone
on since the beginning of time and the
reason that roe v-- wade was was ruled
as it was it's because the docs stood in
front of the Supreme Court and said
please stop the butchery the new health
care bill is still being considered by
the Senate and we likely won't know its
exact contents until it passes this bill
does not have funding for Planned
Parenthood that's important the
reconciliation bill advances the
pro-life cause even further also unclear
is how cutting off Planned Parenthood
funding will impact the uninsured the
addicted and the poor here's the thing
though I think people are
misunderstanding planned parents been
around a hundred years we're gonna be
around a hundred more the question isn't
really what's gonna happen to plan
parity question to me is what's gonna
happen to women low-income women women
in rural America women in small-town
America who have very little access to
affordable health care
hey this is Danny goal with aj+
you can check out the rest of our
divided America series where we examine
the tech elite embracing the prepper
movement refugees fleeing the US for
Canada the battle over land rights in
America and the attempt to defund
Planned Parenthood right now on the aj+
YouTube channel thanks for watching